it's a fair question he won't tell you
we did not agree on the candidates
asking each other that my son's Governor
it's your turn well listen I know that
Charlie's interested in talking about
2024 and Joe Biden but I just want to
make things very very clear the only
worn out old donkey I'm looking to put
out the pasture is Charlie Chris
[Applause]
all right people I'm Dave Rubin this is
the Reuben report it is October 25th
2022 it is 11 30 p.m Eastern yes we are
doing this live stream a half hour late
uh because I was at the Florida
gubernatorial debate last night which
was about three hours north of here it
was in Fort Pierce I'm down here in
Miami there was crazy traffic this
morning I had to drop off Fox news's
Lisa booth at her condo traffic
everywhere lizards in the street
peacocks the whole thing anyway here we
are uh I was at the debate last night
we're going to show you a couple clips
from that in some respects it was kind
of anti-climactic because this is
obviously going to be a spectacular
bloodbath red everywhere here in Florida
but there were a couple interesting
things that I took note of last night
that I wanted to to translate to you
guys in case you either are just seeing
clips about it or watching it on TV
because what happens actually in the
room room is often quite different than
what gets across across the electronic
waves out there before we get to that
and then we're going to be doing a a
Reuben report locals Community Q a and
then I want to show you also some clips
of uh Ted Cruz who was on The View
yesterday and he brought the receipts
they started asking him about uh about
election fraud and questioning elections
and the man literally
I got the receipts ladies so we're going
to get into that too but real quick very
important that we address up top you
know yesterday
we showed you some clips of a chick by
the name of Dylan Mulvaney so this is a
uh this is a guy who transitioned he's a
woman and now he was Quest you know
asking questions of President Biden and
Biden muddled through a couple of
ridiculous answers but there was a there
was an internal debate here at the
Reuben report whether Dylan the woman
Dylan had a penis or not because that
does sort of change the thing like if
you're going full trans and you're gonna
actually do all the stuff as an adult
I'll give you some credit like you're
all in on it at that level but it turns
out Dylan has a penis so I'm just saying
it there it is okay not our most proud
moment here at the Reuben report but I
just felt like you know where people ask
us to give information that's what we do
here uh okay so let's uh let's just dive
right into the debate last night before
I get to the clip so I want to say one
interesting thing that you you probably
would not have gotten if you were
watching this thing on TV so you know
what they do there at the theater is
each campaign is allowed to invite x
amount of people so on the DeSantis side
let's say they were I don't know I'd say
there was roughly 200 people on each
side something like that on the DeSantis
side it was all uh individual people it
was ran you know people like me and
people that were probably friends with
the campaign and maybe some family
members just like a random mismatch of
people and everyone was kind of dressed
they they told us you know dress kind of
business attire so I was something like
this right like my normal attire and it
was just like a whole bunch of
interesting people and or like
nondescript is my point
on the Chris side it they bust in
teachers union people they were all
wearing the exact same t-shirt they were
all chanting at the exact same times
they specifically said before the debate
began uh no cheering no applauding just
let the guys do their thing for an hour
and then you can applaud it you can
apply at the beginning and you can pull
it at the end no interrupting the entire
way through the crisp people were
screaming we're yelling a few of them
had to be removed and then what happened
was the DeSantis people who were
listening to the rules right because we
played by rules these people have no
rules and they also don't represent
themselves like they all just represent
they represent an idea like we're
teachers union people or we're abortion
people or we're mask people a lot of
them were masked also uh but they don't
represent individual people but once
they were shouting and screaming and not
playing by the rules then the DeSantis
people finally started shouting and
screaming a little bit more anyway I
thought that was just worth noting
because if you watch something on TV and
you hear one side applauding and
cheering and screaming and the other
side not you think it is indicative of
something that's going on in that room
but it really wasn't
anyway I'm going to show you two clips
uh from the governor and then I'll tell
you a little something else on on the
Charlie Crist side uh here is Governor
DeSantis defending his parents rights
and education bill you know I would say
when you oppose the parents rights and
education bill which prevents
six seven eight-year-olds from having
sexuality gender ideology injected in
their curriculum you are the one that's
waging the culture War I'm simply
defending parents and students because
it's inappropriate to have that in
elementary school it's inappropriate to
tell a sixth grade a six-year-old that
they were born in the wrong body it's
inappropriate to tell an eight-year-old
that they may have been born a girl but
maybe they're really a boy that's wrong
we need to do the basics we need to
teach them to read write add and
subtract and if we do that we'll
continue to lead in fourth grade reading
and fourth grade math like we did in
today's nape results which is a great
Testament of having open schools and a
lot of hard-working folks in our school
system I also signed and I'm the I'm the
father of a five-year-old daughter and a
two-year-old daughter as well as a
four-year-old son but my daughters are
very athletic and we sign legislation to
protect the right of women athletes that
you should not have someone competing on
the men's team for three years and then
switch to the women's team Charlie Chris
deposed that bill he said he vetoed it
I'm going to protect women's sports in
the state of Florida
all right so you guys got it you get all
the stuff around don't say gay and
actually protecting girls and and just
he was just explaining his record which
he consistently did quite well Chris
lied about literally everything I mean
absolutely everything he was going after
the governor for not following the
science and then going after him on
lockdown stuff I mean it was really
really crazy here's one more this is uh
the governor defending his rejection of
locking down Florida and I would also
say this you mentioned Liz that people
are flocking to Florida that would not
have happened if Charlie Chris had his
way he wrote me a letter in July of 2020
saying you need to shut down the State
of Florida he said you need to force
people to shelter in their own homes
that would have destroyed the State of
Florida that that would have caused that
would have caused our tourism industry
to go into the toilet it would have
locked out millions of kids from school
I rejected Charlie Chris lockdown letter
I kept the state open and I kept the
state free and we now have the biggest
budget surplus in the history of Florida
we have a 2.5 percent unemployment
second lowest on record and we just did
the biggest tax cut in Florida Governor
that's time
so it's interesting because you can hear
some of the Chris people again who were
told not to jeer and cheer and all of
those things so then the DeSantis people
only did it in response later on in the
in the course of the hour but you can
hear them they're cheering for lockdowns
they were cheering for mandates they
were cheering for vaccines it was really
nuts it was to sit in a room you know
it's funny I do this for a living I
watch all the idiotic clips of The View
and MSNBC or whatever but when you sit
in a room and I'm looking at these
people and again they were all dressed
exactly the same because they're not
like a real constituency in that they
are individuals who came together over
good ideas they're sort of brainwashed
NPCs non-playable characters you get the
meme and it was like they wanted more
government to tell them what to do and
when they could leave their house and
inject themselves with things it's it
was so bizarre it really was so bizarre
but I do want to say one other thing
about Charlie Chris and then it's really
not worth talking about much more
because uh everyone gets what's going on
here in Florida and as I said he has no
individual support he has support
through some like woke organizations or
something but there was a certain
asymmetry that was interesting to me to
the debate which was that Governor
DeSantis look obviously I like the guy
obviously I agree with him on virtually
all of the important issues my cards are
on the table right like that's very
clear but he had a record to defend he
had a vision that he was trying to lay
out and he had a reason to be there
right I am the governor I am the chief
executive of this state I am asking you
to to send me back and let's do it again
right he also had a lot to talk about
with you know the the incredible work
that Florida did during this hurricane
and a whole bunch more there was a
reason for him to be on that stage
Charlie Crist was I we I went out with a
bunch of the uh the influencer Twitter
types A bunch of guys that you guys know
from the show Josh hammer and Lisa booth
and John cardillo and Carol marquet's
couple other people and we were all
sitting there after trying to like
describe why we were so frustrated after
because it wasn't like Carly Chris did
anything good that damaged DeSantis but
it was the asymmetry of here we have
like a like an honest broker politics is
a messy game but here's a guy doing good
keeping people free cares about America
all that stuff and here's this other guy
who's just a snake like we were all
trying to come up with a word form
because like chameleon wasn't quite
right he was willing to say and lie
about absolutely everything and and he
was so rude and and just grow he's just
gross and awful and Charlie you got
about 10 days left of this and then you
can crawl back into your little hole and
Method so anyway that's that's all on
that uh we are going to talk about Ted
Cruz going on The View with his receipts
real quick uh let me tell you guys about
Patriot mobile uh you know I recently
did a show on woke corporations and
their Origins uh thankfully
conservatives are creating a parallel
economy that is thriving and I want to
tell you about a new sponsor that's
making a real difference Patriot mobile
has exploded over the last year they are
proud conservatives offering a real
alternative for people tired of funding
major cell phone carriers who have all
gone left Patriot mobile is a force for
conservative values this is because they
take a portion of your bill and fund
conservative causes and candidates
people who actually believe in the
sanctity of Life freedom of speech the
Second Amendment and they're winning in
fact they're packed Patriot mobile
action flipped 11 School Board races
across Texas recently Patriot mobile has
affordable plans for you your family
even your business they offer the same
Nationwide coverage as the major
carriers because they use multiple major
networks so you get the same great
service minus the left is propaganda go
to patriotmobile.com Dave or call 972
Patriot get free activation when you use
offer code Reuben special discounts are
also available for veterans and First
Responders make the switch today and a
difference tomorrow Patriot mobile.com
reubenpatriotmobile.com Ruben or call
972 Patriot and now back to me
so one of the things that I often tell
you guys on this show is that the way we
win well first off we should just be a
little bit better than them and that's
actually not that hard right because
they're hysterical they're mean they're
censorious all of those things they
often don't know what they're talking
about so we can be a little bit better
than them but we can also calmly explain
our positions we can sit there in the
face of adversity in this in the face of
censorship and being called bad names
and not being treated well and we can
actually lay out the truth and I believe
that sunlight is the best disinfectant
so interestingly I don't even know how
this thing happened Senator Ted Cruz
from Texas ends up on The View yesterday
and they're going off on him they're all
ganging up on him including the fake
conservative I think her name's Alyssa
Farah so they've got all you know it's
all lefties and then they have one fake
conservative uh and they're all going
off on him about uh Trump and election
denial and a whole bunch more and Cruz
did not fall for their trap
try to say the election was fair and
square and legitimate you know who y'all
don't do that to you don't do it to
Hillary Clinton who stood up and said
Trump stole the elections
who said who said that the election was
stolen they sat here and said it was
illegitimate and you guys were fine with
it okay so it's illegitimately
Republicans
no you know here's the thing we may not
like when Republicans win but we don't
go and we don't storm we don't try to
change but
[Applause]
did I miss an entire year of antifa
riots where cities across this country
your position is the left doesn't engage
in violence really no they wanted to
know I'm our friend Mike Pence you just
accused us of doing something we didn't
do you said Hillary Clinton didn't say
whatever she didn't say I'm saying to
you listen
okay
[Applause]
Trump is an illegitimate president
Hillary Clinton says the election is
stolen from you Hillary Clinton in 2002
George W Bush was selected Not Elected
Joe Biden Al Gore was was elected
president so Joe Biden yeah
all right so I know you guys got it
right we've played these clips a million
times Hillary Clinton not only did she
tweet that Donald Trump was an
illegitimate president she has said it
on video Russia collusion hoax the
impeachment Stacy Abrams repeatedly
saying that she was the uh rightly
elected governor of Georgia
Etc et cetera like you guys get it but
these people are never confronted the
way that Ted Cruz did and you can see
once they were confronted Whoopi just
doesn't even honestly does not know what
she's saying she's like well you said
whatever you said about whatever you
said and that's what you said and it's
like this is why it's important to stand
our ground and tell them the truth
because they often have blind spots and
and in some ways I don't give the ladies
of the view much of an excuse on this
but if you're if you're just the average
person who just watches mainstream media
I in some ways don't blame you for being
Hoodwinked about all of this right we
would like everyone to be informed and
we'd like people to find other news
shows and online things and all of that
which is of course why they try to
censor the rest of us but the average
person that's out there that's got to
have a job and a family and has other
things to do if they just get little
bits of information and they're not
consumed by politics you wouldn't know
that Hillary twin Hillary Clinton
tweeted the thing about Donald Trump
being an illegitimate president you
might know that about all the you might
not know about all of the video of
Stacey Abrams uh denying the last
election right so in some ways I'm I'm
sympathetic to the people that become I
would say these NPC sort of brainwashed
Lefty robots I am but then there's
another set of people that we really can
work on one of those people that I
really am working on and have have been
working on for quite some time obviously
is Bill Maher and you may remember from
just two weeks ago roughly when I was on
his podcast and he was talking about
Trump and the election I brought up the
Hillary thing and his reaction is pretty
interesting first of all you got to
break up with your boyfriend Donald
Trump who would you say more authentic
him or Joe Biden
him he's more authentic him or Elizabeth
Warren but authentic does it mean good
if you're authentically a crazy person
pretty good when he was president what
what was pretty good we weren't in a
recession the Border was a little bit
better we didn't have a crazy war in
Ukraine like there were things come on
you have to admit he hasn't conceded the
election for four years when he was
president Hillary Clinton he's an
illegitimate president Stacy she didn't
say that yes she did it's on Twitter
he's an illegitimate yes it is it is a
hundred percent okay if she said I I
don't remember that it is it is
certainly not something that's in the
minds of the people in this country it
was not promulgated so maybe she said it
once in some different context it's to
compare that like Hillary Clinton says
he's not no he has made a career bill I
mean total respect I think to me that's
a blind spot with you let that that
Hillary no that he when you just said
that nobody really paid attention to
that or anything a huge percent of the
country half the country saw Hillary
calling him there's a tweet I mean I can
give you the Tweet after okay it's one
tweet no he is
what do you mean how many guests I
honestly don't know the answer so it's a
I don't want to make about you but how
many people are on MSNBC for four years
saying he's a Russian operative or
Russia installed okay so I'm not showing
you that to Pat myself on the back I'm
showing you that there is a way to
calmly have these conversations and as
Bill and I wrapped it up as you know we
we wrapped it up saying hey let's
continue the conversation he invited me
on real time uh we've been texting I'm
going to keep nudging him right and
he'll probably try to keep nudging me
and it's all good but you know what was
interesting his reaction when when I
said to him well Hillary called Trump
and illegitimate illegitimate president
his initial reaction reaction was she
didn't say that and I think this is part
of the problem we all end up in our own
Bubbles and I would include myself in
that we all have to do the best we can
to not be in those bubbles because if
we're all just self-selecting the
information that we have well then you
think you end up with the kind a
political polarization that we have
right now I think that pretty much
answers uh what it is uh let's just jump
back now and again I'm actually not
playing that to blast tomorrow I'm sure
I'm playing it to just show you like a
lot of people don't see the world that
you you're watching this show you see
the world in a certain way right I'm not
hiding information from you uh I'm doing
the best job that I possibly can here
doesn't mean that I'm doing it perfectly
but there's a whole bunch of people like
these people on The View or the people
that watch The View or sometimes maybe a
a you know Lefty Hollywood celebrity
that actually don't see a lot of the
stuff that we do see let's continue here
is Ted Cruz uh giving it back to noted
racist sunny hoston that was standing
now let me ask you the senator the
conservative platform I think was easily
identifiable years ago uh it was limited
government low taxes strengthening
National Defense Family Values I think
it's a little hypocritical for
Republicans to be able to stand behind
Family Values right now having voted in
you know the twice impeached former
disgraced president and backing the
president still uh former president but
in 2020 the Republican Party didn't even
put out an agenda right and I asked this
question on the show all the time what
do the Republicans stand for and what is
the Republican agenda it's very simple
I'll give you three words jobs freedom
and security when it comes to jobs
listen when you cut taxes when you
reduce regulations when small businesses
expand
you have lots and lots of jobs
still sure that the government has
important roles but but let's be clear
under the Trump Administration with
Republican majorities in both houses we
had the lowest unemployment in 50 years
where the lowest African-American
unemployment deficit ever recorded no
not worth 31 trillion now so I agree the
deficit listen I've stood up to my own
party a bunch of times but when you've
got poverty going down we have the
lowest African-American unemployment
ever recorded lowest Hispanic
unemployment ever recorded that's a big
deal
this election in November I think is
going to be a tidal wave I think
Republicans are going to retake both
houses and the biggest reason people at
home are saying okay is my life better
today than it was two years ago and I
think for the vast majority of Americans
the answer is no
man I mean Sonny she's just she's not a
good person and she's not very good at
her job to just hand him that and you
think he was ready three words jobs
Freedom security he could have just like
literally poured gasoline on the table
throwing a match down blown the whole
thing up and that's how the view could
have ended right there and then of
course he calmly explains facts facts
during the last Republican
Administration and I understand lady it
was because of Donald Trump so you're
freaking out but I would think Sunny
host then as someone that sees
everything through a racial lens which
you do uh that you might be happy with
lowest all-time black unemployment but
Trump did it you might be happy with the
lowest all-time Latino unemployment but
Trump did it we know the Border was
better so again this is this is the
exact same thing what Ron DeSantis did
last night defending his record clearly
stating what you believe is exactly what
Ted Cruz did to these people last time
now or yesterday on The View now what's
interesting is because of the bubbles
because so many people don't see reality
as it is they see the world the way they
want it to be not the way it is because
of that when they are confronted by
reality and Clarity they often start
screaming well I'll try to censor you
Etc and of course that's just what
happened yesterday on The View the vast
majority of Americans the answer is no
[Applause]
thank you
yeah that was someone in the view
audience yelling Fu to uh to Ted Cruz
and in some ways you can't blame her
because she has been brainwashed by
those harpies sitting at that table and
now reality was confronting her and what
did she have left well it's yelling
at a senator it's cheering when you're
not supposed to cheer It's Shouting
people down it's making sure people's
posts don't get seen on Facebook or
Twitter or YouTube Etc I think you guys
get it I hope Ted Cruz is cruises right
and I really do think there's going to
be a massive Red Wave we shall see I
think you know look I really we were
talking about it last night I'm telling
you guys I think New York is at play
maybe I'm crazy maybe it's going to end
up going 60 40 hochul and all of the
people who love to hate me will uh post
this video but I really think there's a
chance I think everyone hates the woke I
think every everyone hates the anyone
who has a spark of individuality hates
the woke the woke are they're not a real
thing they're corporations and unions
and just brainwashed people who don't
know what they believe good decent
people want to get back to a good decent
America that is the plan we got 10 days
or so to to make it happen on that note
let's get to the reubenreportlocals.com
Community Q a I have not reviewed the
questions because I ran in here and said
that down and I don't know what I'm
going to be reading but here we go Mara
says could you ever live again in a
state that gets snow come to Wisconsin
and do a show at least maybe not in
January you know look I'm never leaving
Florida I cannot Envision a situation
that would get me out of this place they
can literally when I'm
when I'm dead they can feed me to the
alligators in the Everglades like I love
it love it love it here even just today
just driving up the coast uh you know
Fort Pierce it's maybe an hour and a
half north of Fort Lauderdale so I had
about a three hour drive down and it's
just it's gorgeous the palm trees the
green the water the people the economy
the sense of Freedom The Joy the smiles
the whole thing I'm not leaving Florida
but David does miss the seasons a little
more than I do I'm totally fine like
without the seasons I I even like the
hot humid summer here it was not that
bad but he does uh he's from the DC area
he misses some of the seasons
um I guess we could go skiing maybe
we'll come out to Wisconsin hang out
have some cheese then we can go skiing
in Colorado or something like that but
yeah I think Florida it is my now and it
is my future Lauren says what would
someone need to do to earn the call to
be interviewed by you that's interesting
I mean you know look a certain
amount of people are just you know
they're in the political machine right
they're in that that stream of politics
so their senators or or congressmen or
political pundits and all that thing so
then you're kind of in there then
there's you know just random people that
pop up that suddenly you're like wait a
minute I never heard of this person but
they're doing something special there
was once a uh a Canadian psychology
Professor who a lot of people you know
he was talking about Peter Pan and
people thought he was nuts and I said
we're going to put this guy on the show
turned out to be Jordan Peterson uh you
never know you know there was a uh a
professor a biology professor at this
tiny little College uh that nobody had
ever heard of Evergreen State who uh
start got kicked off campus for being
anti-racist turned out to be Brett
Weinstein you just never know there was
a a girl whose YouTube handle was red
pill black I did not even know her name
until we sat down in my studio she
turned out to be Candace Owens so you
know I think I have some level of a feel
for for who I should be talking to and
when I should be talking to them
um you know sometimes it's like you know
there's people doing a press junket like
you got a book and you know let's talk
about that but I always try to link
everything to current events and that
sort of thing but I'm open and that's
why I take you know you guys and locals
you guys are giving me names all the
time and we we've got a master list and
some of those names do get on there uh
schmoo says Dave can you tell me why any
sane person in Florida would ever take
such a flip-flopping finger to the wind
political fool such as Charlie Chris
seriously and actually vote for him
that's the thing I mean I'm telling you
there was there was this real asymmetry
that felt gross that's why we were all
having trouble coming up with a word to
describe Christ because you have one
person who's an honest arbiter
like doing the right thing leading to
this freedom-loving functional State and
then you have this guy Charlie Crist
used to be a pro-life Republican now
he's an eight-month pro-choice Democrat
right like Charlie Crist used to be a
closet he was closeted gay everyone in
Florida knew it I'm sorry that I'm
saying this everyone in Florida when he
was governor knew he was gay and
closeted and anti-gay now he's got all
the Rainbow crew out there applauding
him right and then he had his his new
girlfriend showed up at the end to hug
him he tried to actually shake her hand
at first it was actually hilarious I
wish it was on video she goes up there
so at the end you know they send the
women up so Casey DeSantis comes up and
you can see they just love each other
it's so obvious and real and there's a
hug and a warmth and a joy then they
bring up Charlie Chris it's a beard it's
a fake relationship right he got her a
couple weeks ago and he literally put
his hand out to like shake her hand and
then and then they have their fake
anyway I don't even care about that uh
suffice to say he used to be a a
Conservative Republican who now became a
banana Anna's Lefty nothing I think in
essence what happened here in Florida is
that they knew DeSantis was going to
crush it they they knew his ideas are
the future of the Republican Party
there's no real mainstream support for
Democrats here so they needed some they
really just needed some loser some like
just guy who could put on a suit and
could the guy put on the suit and
basically stand there Charlie Christ
also did they announced right before the
debate he requested to have a small fan
on stage so he had a little fan just on
him to take care of the flop sweat
anyway everything he said was a lie or a
distortion of the truth like it was
really really gross real clear politics
by the way at Nate Silver's 538
currently have DeSantis up by 11 points
I I hope it will be more than that that
would be massive he won his last
election Ron DeSantis over uh Andrew
Gillum who turned out to be a meth
addict uh he won it by about 30 000
votes so if he gets something like you
know so that's basically less than one
percent if he gets 10 percent eleven
percent like that is a freaking message
and that is a message that should be
heard Marissa says what is the one thing
about Parenthood you didn't expect oh
that I didn't know I guess I expected
the diapers I expected waking up at
night
um
I expected the happy Parts too like
waking up in the morning especially when
I have Justin now in the morning where
he's smiling more to like directly when
I'm you know like talking to him and
like I tell them like I sometimes you
know I do some silly voices and that
kind of stuff and like accents but I try
not I don't baby him like I don't talk
like a baby but I just like say like
silly things but then sometimes I'll
kind of like go through what I'm doing
on the show today you know and I'm like
sitting there Phoenix and I are texting
back and forth what the clips are going
to be and I'll be like Justin what do
you think about this Ted Cruz
um what has been the biggest surprise
um
you know life kind of just keeps going
it keeps going it feels Fuller but it
just kind of keeps going and and uh it
was a long road to get here but but we
got there and it's good uh me says do
you think Bill Maher has Trump
derangement syndrome during the podcast
he seemed to deviate from his more
reasonable Persona and go off the rails
whenever you two talked about him yeah I
mean to some extent yes right like Trump
derangement syndrome the idea that that
Meme came into being because there were
these people who suddenly seemed and I'm
not including bill on this fully but
there was like a group of people we all
know these people who were like pretty
moderate people usually they were sort
of moderate old school Democrats but
some of them were moderate Republicans
and then Trump was just as Gad sad calls
it an aesthetic injury to them right
like they couldn't believe that he eats
his steak well done with ketchup and
that he goes to McDonald's and likes a
burger or that he said grab them by the
[ __ ] or whatever it is like the stuff
and it's not to defend any of the odd
things that he said or any of those
things but they just felt if if they can
make him be the worst thing possible I
think they think it excuses all of their
excesses and I'm not perfect but you
know it's like I can accept that I don't
need to like [ __ ] on somebody else to
make myself feel good about myself I
think a lot of people do that
um I would say in Bill's case it's a
little more of what I referenced a few
minutes ago
where he's in a somewhat La let's say
liberal leftist bubble so his reaction
when I said well Hillary Clinton called
him an illegitimate uh illegitimate
pregnant an illegitimate president
his reaction was no no he no she didn't
and it was so off the cuff that it was
like I believe that that's what he
believes but that shows you how we all
have to make sure we don't have those uh
those blind spots because if we do we
will just live in different worlds and
we will try to destroy each other maybe
that's kind of what we've been doing uh
Cobalt says what are your favorite
places to visit in Broward County you
know since we've been down here I really
have not done much outside of my little
My Little Miami bubble right over here
um but where are my favorite places I
really Coconut Grove is really fantastic
is that even technically in Broward
that's Miami-Dade yeah what's in Broward
Fort Lauderdale I guess
what Hollywood oh well I've been to uh
the Hard Rock Hotel in uh in Hollywood a
couple times I'm actually going to see a
concert there next month I've been up
there for uh well Ben's studio is up
there in that area and the valutainment
studios up there with Patrick David and
a bunch of other people uh but the Hard
Rock Hotel if you haven't been there
it's a casino also and it's just like a
fun atmosphere there's a the restaurants
are fantastic it's a cool spot uh Naomi
says You seem like a very generous
person as and as your personal wealth
has grown how does it feel to know you
can give more to others
um
I guess pretty good you know I it's
weird I had I was very poor for a long
time and I was like literally going
through change uh buckets till I get
coffee when I was in New York City and
when I was doing stand-up and not making
any money I think I've told this on the
show before I had a buddy who worked in
a food service for a food service
company and he would literally deliver
me giant like vacuum sealed packages of
tuna that were like industrial size and
I would eat tuna day after day after day
and big things of soup my sodium and my
mercury levels were probably through the
freaking roof so I've had the lean years
obviously the last couple years have
been really good and we're building
something that's really good here and
and you know the Reuben report company
is solid uh started locals which I put
money into an awful lot of work for no
money for a long time and then
eventually we merged with Rumble and
like there's a lot of good things here
um how does it feel know you can give
more to others I mean I guess that's
good like when I see gofundme's that are
worth uh supporting I do but I think my
my better value is that if I keep
building things then I can help other
people like the guys in this room do the
things that they want to do in their
lives like I don't think I don't think
just giving you I know you don't mean it
this way but like just the throwing
money and things I don't think is fully
the answer I think you can do more and
and treat people well and take people
out to dinner and do all of those things
and I like doing it I like doing it and
I also I've always had like a weird
thing with money which is sort of I've
always kind of felt you have to spend it
to make it like sometimes like if
something big comes in you know I get a
big speaking gig or something and we get
this check and I'm kind of like I gotta
get rid of that money because we need
more money to come in I don't know if
that really makes any sense maybe
there's a little bit of a secret in
there or something
um
but yeah it's uh it's pretty it's better
to have a little something than uh you
know constantly be trying to rub two
nickels together uh Phoenix roll with me
here uh Dan says you took the first
steps with Bill Maher who would you say
is the next likely person in that realm
that uh could see the light
uh well I wish I could say that it would
have probably been Sam Harris who you
know was hugely influential on me for
years but I think he's uh I think that
the Trump derangement thing that we've
discussed I think that that's caused him
to kind of go off the deep end and you
know he calls for the censorship of of
trump and you know he's he's said a
whole bunch of Bizarro things and I
think turned his back on on a bunch of
decent people
um I think maybe one that would be
somewhat relevant and I would welcome
her to come on the show any time is
Barry Weiss you know formerly of the New
York Times had to leave because it was
too woke
um you know but with all of these people
you know that that whole crew of like
the people that are kind of on the fence
the non-woke libs it's like I would love
to challenge any of them right now if
any of them are watching this or you
want to send this video to any of them
and I'm not talking about any specific
person but that whole crew of people if
you say you're a non-woke lib you're an
old school liberal we got an election in
two weeks how about you publicly say who
you're going to vote for not even in
state you know even if you don't live in
the state like who would you vote for if
you lived in Pennsylvania if you're a
non-woke lib who would you vote for
would you vote for John Federman let's
let all the criminals out let's chop off
kids genitals eight-month abortions or
would you vote for Dr Oz who obviously
is not some crazed far Rider you know
he's probably an old school Democrat
which makes him somewhat of a moderate
conservative and I think he'll continue
shifting a little more to the right but
like how about we just challenge all of
these people uh these these political
pundits these people who in this world
like what what would you do if you were
in all these states if you were in
Arizona what would you be doing right
now would you be voting for Blake
Masters or not and if not why otherwise
to just say you're sort of non-woke
liberal it just doesn't mean anything
and I think that that's why
um
well that's why having these
conversations with some of these people
has gotten more difficult for me it's
why the conversation with Bill Maher was
so good because he was still willing to
have it I think a lot of them they see
me and it's like I kind of I mean this
is a pat on my back I suppose but it's
like I got to the end of the road I got
to the end of the road so I can vote uh
in in a fashion that makes sense to my
ideals and my values they're struggling
to do that and I would love to know if
we could get more of those people over
that that is the great challenge I think
that I think the proof will be in the
pudding by the way over the next couple
weeks I think you're going to see an
awful lot of sort of old school liberals
New York even you could call them New
York liberals whatever you want to call
them I think an awful lot of them have
had it with hochul again nobody ever
voted for hotel because they installed
her uh and I think a lot of them are
going to go for zeldon so there might be
something shifting right now there might
be janzi says I know you love tequila
what is the one alcoholic beverage you
will never touch mine is tequila what
listen you got to get that class Azul
Reposado get it on one rock swirl it a
little bit it's just Heavenly
um what is the one alcohol I don't like
um what's that there's like that
cinnamon Fireball thing like they drink
it in college what the hell is that
thing what's it called it's called
Fireball is that what it's called
Fireball I don't like it
I don't like it and I'm not gonna drink
it
Tony says if you could wave a magic wand
and delete a government agency which one
would it be I don't know I mean there's
so many options here how about the EPA
right the Environmental Protection
Agency which came in with a very sort of
limited role of guidelines on how
certain companies were going to do
certain things related to the
environment but it has become a giant
bureaucratic Albatross that thinks it
has control over Industries at this
point and is basically doing no good it
is it you could but you could cut so
many federal agencies you could just you
could take out the Department of
Education you really could and it would
do it would create no problem kick it
back to the States let parents make more
choices yeah
Perdue says hi Dave as president doesn't
Biden have the power to resist efforts
to get him off the 24 ticket
well I suppose he has the power to do it
right no one can stop him from running
for the presidency it would be
interesting if it came to blows meaning
that the whole apparatus of the party
was like Joe uh you got dementia
everything's in the [ __ ] we don't
want you and if Joe was just like no I'm
the titular there's the word of the day
I'm the titular head of the party and
I'm still running like I don't know that
that's ever happened before in American
politics certainly not in modern times
but that would be an interesting thing
because I think he's so mentally
compromised and so has he's so out of it
that for all we know he really thinks
he's doing a good job he really thinks
that he's fine and the Machinery after
the bloodbath hopefully in in 10 days or
so is going to really turn against him
will he have the wherewithal to walk
away I don't know I think it probably
depends what Dr Jill decides to do with
him maybe she'll diagnose him finally
now that she's a doctor but it's going
to be a very very weird two years for
the Democrats assuming the Republicans
take the house in the Senate because
they they need the party must be
destroyed
that's it and I say that as someone that
once was a Democrat has Democrat family
members and wishes that there was a
functional Democratic Party by the way
that's what I kept thinking last night
during the debate it was like if Charlie
Christ had walked up there and instead
of just lying about everything and
standing for nothing and just being like
a sniveling grotesque coward if he had
gotten up there and honestly said what
he believes
whatever that might be
and and that that and then said and
because of those Reasons I'm a Democrat
well that would be pretty nice because
then we could debate the issues like
it's pretty obvious you don't have to
like this anthis okay there's plenty of
people who don't like the scientist I
think they're misguided but there's
plenty of people don't like them but
it's not because they don't know what he
believes right like everything Charlie
Chris said was like he was you know and
then he fought with Mickey Mouse and
it's like well what was he actually
fighting with uh Charlie and isn't it
good when politicians fight with
corporations that are indoctrinating
like all of it was such a nonsensical
thing but yes would it be nice if there
was a Democrat Party that stood for
Democrat ideals even if I don't believe
in them anymore right uh wouldn't that
be good yeah I think it kind of would
darlena says do you think there will be
more violence towards Republican voters
as the Democrats start to panic about
the polls leaning towards the Red Wave
this election
I mean it sort of feels like there will
be what I would be more concerned about
is if the machine really feels that even
though Joe Biden will still be president
until they get rid of him but if the
Republicans take the house in the Senate
and there's a real feeling that
Republicans can do things legislatively
or really stop this woke thing or really
start you know like doing tax cuts I
don't know the Biden would sign them but
whatever it might be they might just
want to unleash the violence again and
and you really need to understand that
the violence was coordinated and
Unleashed what happened to that summer
of black lives matter did they solve
racism did antifa solve fascism or were
they being manipulated and coordinated
because it was a plan to destroy cities
because somehow it would make Trump look
bad and then you throw in some cobit on
top of that and everything else
I think I think the answer is fairly
obvious so I think it depends what the
leadership or what the the people who
are pulling the strings want to do Ethan
says my son is being born right now as
you're reading this holy cow Ethan uh
any tips from the devil's son expert wow
well first off congratulations and you
should probably get off your phone
um but uh my what would my advice be man
I don't know that I'm in the position of
giving advice yet just be good and enjoy
them enjoy them like you know
I'm telling you man to start the day
with a kid in your hands instead of this
thing it's good it is good
um get them outside one thing that I've
noticed depends where you live I suppose
in terms of the weather but one thing
I've noticed is if either one of them is
crying little fussy little gas whatever
it is if I just pick them up take them
outside wander around we have a nice
little water fountain outside so it
makes some nice little water crashing
sounds just a little of that a little
bit of nature I like to sit under the
trees and oh little lizards you know
they're not quite seeing everything yet
but I think getting outside is a good
thing we try to start the day with the
walk which now we got a double stroller
so I used to be cool man Lloyd says do
you believe the NRC should start pulling
cards of rhinos like Liz Cheney and Mitt
Romney we are appalled that Romney is
not endorsing a teammate Mike Lee but
has come out positively for his opponent
a supposed independent wholly financed
by Blue dollars I did not know that so
so Romney is not supporting Mike Lee
who's in the Senate Mike who I've had on
the show who is a good decent man who
cares about America and he's a
constitutional conservative I mean the
guy knows what he believes and why he
believes it so Romney is supporting Evan
McMuffin
McMuffin that's what I call him it's
Mick Mullen but I call him McMuffin
um who's nothing right he's base he's an
independent who's really a Democrat wow
I did not know Romney was that far gone
yeah look I think one thing that
Republicans have to do
and everyone can thank Trump for this is
Republicans need to get balls get some
balls you've got balls the other people
are the ones chopping off the balls
you've got some balls use your balls use
your balls for good okay you can do use
your balls for good didn't Yoda say that
for good you'll lose your balls
like there needs enough of this enough
of these wishy-washy people it doesn't
mean everyone needs to be like some
crazy political extremist obviously but
fight fight for what you believe that is
very disappointing in Romney obviously I
have no love for Romney he's just kind
of nothing basically a Democrat he just
wants the machine to like him okay fine
but that he's not supporting Mike Lee
who is his colleague his his Republican
colleague in the Senate wow I'd really
like to know more about that let's let's
look into that maybe cover it later in
the week
um okay Elizabeth says uh I can't
believe I mean I can but you know what
they did to that Rubio staffer and yet
they say that Maga Republicans are
violent what are your thoughts on this
terrible incident that occurred in Miami
so there was uh if you didn't see it it
was either yesterday or the day before
uh in Hialeah which is a little bit
north of Miami there was a canvass or a
young kid how old was he was probably
about 21-22 young I think he may I think
maybe he was Latino his race does not
matter to me but in a racialized world I
suppose it's worth mentioning uh he was
canvassing with a Rubio shirt on and he
got attacked
by a bunch of people they're trying to
figure it out but I mean he got brutally
brutally assaulted uh you know wounds
all over his face and body I mean the
pictures are rather gruesome I tweeted
it out the image of him and I said you
know there's a hundred percent certainty
that this will not be on CNN tonight and
I have no doubt that it was not on CNN
yesterday now try to do a different
version of it right it's a campaigner
for Stacy Abrams who gets attacked by
Republicans you think this you think
you're going to hear about this on CNN
and again that gets to what we started
with on the show this sort of why they
have to censor why so many people and
confronted with reality freak out
because they are so disconnected from
what actual reality is
um if they're I asked on Twitter I don't
know that anyone saw it if there's a
GoFundMe for this kid I would love to
donate absolutely do we know how old he
is or anything we're not 22 years old
yeah I mean really just absolute
absolute disgusting and and to that the
fact that that happened in Florida where
things are really regardless of your
your political differences you know even
yesterday again I'm sitting in a theater
probably 200 DeSantis supporters 200 uh
they're not even Chris supporters
they're just 200 people who are just
doing the thing at the moment that makes
them feel good
um but you know like we weren't at each
other's throats maybe we were thinking
all sorts of things but we weren't
throwing things at each other and being
mean and everybody left after but it was
it really I'm telling you it was just so
interesting because outside the venue
there were all these people with
DeSantis flags and American flags and
some Trump flags and playing music and
it was fun and whatever and then the
Chris people all showed up together like
I'm telling you it was coordinated he
does not have real support he has he has
these sort of like uh these blanket
supports from these unions and type
things but they they don't represent
individuals and individuals are the root
of Western Civilization ladies and
gentlemen uh stick around for a cold
close uh as always like And subscribe on
YouTube Rumble and join us if you want
to play along during the show at
reubenreport.locals.com uh part one of
my interview with Andrew klavan of the
daily wire who's got a new book out and
he's just one of the most thoughtful
interesting people around who I've had
on the show many times and he's a good
buddy he's up right now the full thing's
up ad free at locals and I Leave You
with Joe Biden getting lost adios
I noticed how much freedom I have
foreign